how to sell something you've never done
before so I got a great question from
what I YouTube viewers love you guys
drew who wrote in to say great video but
what if you can't feel confident because
you've never done it before how do you
present a great idea to a business for
example how to increase their customers
or make a certain process much easier
which you know will work but you've
never done it before thanks June my
quick simple advice is go do it go get a
little bit of experience and show them
that it works or start with one client
even if it's for free or refunds I cost
whatever it is just to get something
under your belt to help you make your
process better and show that it actually
works right that helps give you a better
reputation here's a couple examples from
my personal story and hopefully this
helps guide a little bit of light so I
told the story a few times when I
started creating blogs for companies the
company approached me and said hey we
want you to write this blog post for us
and I said sure why not you know they're
gonna pay me 500 box I get a link to my
website it's a big brand so why not and
I over-deliver like crazy and I gave
them way more than they wanted I
promoted and I made videos and just way
more than they ever expected and I had
such a great impact that it was way more
than they ever thought they would get
and they hired me and they hired nine
other bloggers and I was the only one
that they kept from the start because of
the results that i got and then i
started increasing my prices and it went
from five hundred to a thousand the 1500
to 2000 2500 and now if you want me to
write content for your blog it's gonna
cost twenty-five hundred dollars we're
going to get way better results than
hiring anybody else and i can go to
companies and say that with legitimacy
it's not just me knowing that it works
is that i've done this right i've proven
it and i know i know it works does i can
I've done it before here are the
examples right and so I'm not going to
go off to some company say hey I'm going
to do this it's going to cost 100 boxing
or look at me say hey I'm nuts show me
some proof and I've got nothing but just
other people's work the
back it up need another example we have
launched a new program off my website
it's a movement program helping
entrepreneurs build their movements I've
built one around believe and I want
other entrence build it around there's
two it's not cheap its twenty five
thousand dollars a year to sign up for
the movement program how can I sell that
well one I built my own I'm modeling
what I've done for myself to help other
entrepreneurs do the same thing and 2
i've helped people in small ways do it
already so entrepreneurs in my circle
I've helped them with their movements
I've helped them find out what their one
word is I've helped them create their
social media campaign I help them get
started and now I'm just formalizing it
cuz people come to me and I've done you
know meetings and one on one just
because I wanted to help them and I'm
formalizing the process to help people
in a structured way and so I have the
experience that kind of back it up and
so my best advice is go out and start
doing it you should be the gut you're
the man to help entrepreneurs increase
their customer base or make things more
efficient right and that comes by
building up reputation by working with
some company and it can happen quickly
but you got to get started so even if
your first customer is free or your
first customer is at a really reduced
cost you got to get some experience with
credibility a track record and here's a
newsflash you know everything that
you've learned is great up until now but
once you start working with a client
you'll get new ideas you'll find that
some of the things you thought were
didn't work and you'll end up with a
much tighter much better system you do
this a couple times you'll have the drew
methodology that then you can serve and
charge a premium for because you've
shown that it works for these companies
you've got to build up a little bit of
track record because for for companies
are going to hire me there's a huge risk
factor right it's like whoa what if it
doesn't work I'm spending how much money
what if it doesn't work I mean the
easiest way around that is to have some
kind of some kind of results oriented
target in there but they can be so hard
to measure and its really trust in the
company
but really you just got to go out and
get some experience do it a couple times
show that it works prove it halve the
droop portfolio the people from looked
insane wow look what he did I want to I
want some drew I want some of that in my
business and if you can make that happen
for a few companies word of mouth will
spread right those business owners will
tell other people yeah you know what
this guy drew came in just changed my
life and you know what now it's not free
anymore now it's two hundred bucks and
then it's 500 bucks and a thousand bucks
and then it's 2,000 bucks right as you
keep adding more value and as your time
gets limited right because you're in
demand you can keep increasing with
prices that's how you build a solid
business believe those you watching i
love to hear what you have to think
leave a comment below let me know how
you got your first customer how you
built this thing up that your business
is all about let me know in the comments
below you have other advice for jus i'm
sure you'd love to hear it too if you
want to leave feedback you like to do to
give it a thumbs up below click on my
face subscribe to the channel thank you
so much and I'll see you soon